discours solennel et très court
d'emmanuel macron nous serons sans
faiblesse a dit le chef de l'état nous
répondrons avec sang froid
il annonce de prochaines sanctions sur
le plan militaire sur le plan de
l'énergie c'est un tournant dit il dans
l'histoire de l'europe il y aura des
conséquences sur nos vies emmanuel
macron donc qui a énormément de réunions
à venir une réunion du g7 le sommet
européen ce soir sommet de l'otan
roselyne febvre c'est une première prise
de parole il y en aura d'autres mais une
prise de parole est essentielle et là
c'est typiquement le chef de guerre qui
est apparu à ces quelques minutes à la
fois pour rassurer pour dire qu' il
était afin que l'europe ne faiblirait
pas qu'on était effectivement un
tournant vous savez emmanuel macron a
toujours eu cette phrase si on écoute
ses discours depuis cinq ans il a
toujours cette expression le retour du
tragique et le tragique de l'histoire
c'est quelque chose qu'il qui dit
toujours comme si ils avaient
l'appréhension de ce test de cette
histoire tragique donc c'est à la fois
pour rassurer match is ce discours n'est
pas très rassurant mais rassurés au fil
aussi des de ses allocutions parce que
qu'elle aide la france et l'europe vont
donner ça va poser des biens sur des
problèmes migratoires des problèmes
économiques des prix de l'énergie
d'amples en jeu est extrêmement
important alors je suis désolé mais en
fait on ne voudrait pas sorti le micro
et on ne vous entend pas visiblement
alors pas bien donc on va on va vous
équiper peut-être un mot bruno avant
qu'on en est quitte roselyne sur cette
prise de parole on retiendra voilà la
détermination des manuels macron nous
serons sans faiblesse a dit le chef de
l'état oui c'est une déclaration assez
martial effectivement dans le ton après
sur la forme ça sur la forme je veux
dire après sur le fond est bien emmanuel
macron il peut dire que nous allons
prendre des sanctions encore plus
sévères vis-à-vis de la russie il n'est
pas allé comme vient de le faire son
homologue britannique boris johnson
jusqu'à qualifié vladimir poutine de
dictateurs puisque c'est le terme que
vient d'employés le premier ministre
britannique manuel macro lui reste sur
un ton plus plus neutre il parle aussi
de vrais changements géopolitiques sur
le continent qui auront des conséquences
durables économique notamment et puis il
seulement ça c'est plutôt de à roselyne
de nous le dire il se place en chef de
guerre qui veut protéger le peuple
français mais en tout cas on sent bien
que à quelques semaines de l'élection
présidentielle il est pris dans cette
crise il est obligé
de réagir en plus il est président du
conseil de l'union européenne et donc en
fait il affirme simplement que l'heure
est grave mais après comme les autres
européens le problème c'est que
évidemment il n'y aura pas des deux
militaires à l'ukraine et malgré
l'ampleur des sanctions que vont décider
les européens et des américains des
nouvelles sanctions eh bien les
occidentaux vont quelque part assisté un
peu impuissant à à ce que veut et va
faire vladimir poutine en ukraine dans
les prochaines heures et les prochains
jours et c'est quand même un rapport de
force qui n'est pas en faveur des
occidentaux à cause bien sûr de l'ombre
de l'armé nucléaire les hawks des russes
et aussi du coût des américains des
français des britanniques car que si on
commence à affronter les russes eh bien
il vient un danger vladimir poutine a
laissé que très clairement entendre
d'utilisation de l'armé nucléaire donc
c'est la limite de l'exercice
roselyne je vous ai coupé désolé
voilà le micro elle fausse écoute le
monde vous écoute
c'est un il a prononcé le mot d' acte de
guerre et que l'europe ne faiblirait pas
que la france aussi serait aux côtés des
ukrainiens il s'agissait aussi de dire
que à la fois que l'heure est grave
effectivement mais de rassurer les
français en a pas il n'en a pas vraiment
le temps il a un peu donné son agenda
avec ce ou ces réunions le g7 et le
sommet européen et le sommet de l'otan
parce que les la problématique et les
français se posent aussi des questions
sur ce que ça va les indiens le
chamboulement de de cette guerre c'est à
dire la migraine et les questions
migratoires bien évidemment l'économie
avec le prix de l'énergie puisque le gaz
etc donc c'était une façon il n'ya pas
vraiment rassuré aujourd'hui les
français mais il le fera sans doute et
puis une discussion au parlement pour
montrer aussi que eh bien il ne décide
pas seul il y aura un débat au parlement
il sera sans doute en demande d'unité
nationale parce qu'on a vu quand même
que beaucoup sur la scène politique pour
maintenance depuis l'acte de guerre de
vladimir poutine bien évidemment on a vu
quand même un jean luc mélenchon parler
de la russie qui était devenu un
agresseur voilà marine le pen et zemmour
qui vis-à-vis de la russie était
beaucoup plus clément je pense que le
ton va changer et que tout le monde va
forcément emmanuel macron va rechercher
de l'unité nationale et montrer aussi
que lors de ce débat à l'assemblée
nationale il n'est pas seul à décider
parce que il est aussi dans une position
de bientôt candidat 1 puisque c'est le 4
mars que la clotte que le conseil
constitutionnel d'un à la clôture dans
huit jours dans huit jours voilà des
candidatures donc là il est plus
question d'un emmanuel macron candidat
mais d'un emmanuel macron danseurs dans
son rôle de président bien évidemment
bien obligé personne va le presser
personne va lui demander alors est ce
que vous êtes candidat c'est pas le
sujet pour l'instant donc il va comme il
l'a dit être président de la république
jusqu'au dernier quart d'heure et
peut-être que avant 18 heures le 4 mars
il se déclara une heure peut-être avant
on l'a déjà vu une campagne aussi
chamboulé par une crise internationale
majeure papa depuis pas depuis longtemps
bien évidemment c'est une c'est une
une circonstance gravissime qui demande
toute l'attention d'un président de la
république et toute l'attention aussi
d'une classe politique qui doit être
responsable c'est à dire qu'elle ne doit
pas tirer dans les pattes d'un président
comme on a pu l'entendre parfois sur les
critiques que les essais
diplomatique d' emmanuel macron certes
qui ont été vains mais dont c'était le
rôle personne ne lui reprochera d'avoir
tenté mais aujourd'hui c'est de rassurer
les français
sur cette cette guerre qui est à nos
portes et quelles en seront les
conséquences
et surtout est-ce que un moment ou un
autre la france va s'engager
militairement c'est toute la question
mais ça se fera avec l'europe mais c'est
ce qui c'est ce qui est en tout cas fait
peur aux français aujourd'hui bruno wiel
sûr sur cette intervention militaire qui
est riner est hypothétique pour
l'instant en tout cas l'intervention
militaire directement de soldats
français américains ou britanniques sur
le sol ukrainien je pense que c'est
impensable
sauf si vraiment vladimir poutine ce
n'est as a dévasté a ravagé totalement
l'ukraine et encore puisque l'ukraine et
la pologne oui alors ça c'est autre
chose voilà en revanche appuie alors
après tout tous les autres pays qui
étaient donc des d'anciens pays sous la
tutelle soviétique sont aujourd'hui des
pays de l'otan les pays bas la pologne
la hongrie la slovaquie la roumanie et
là il ya un renforcement ce sera sans
doute l'objet du sommet de l'otan demain
va y avoir un renforcement des
dispositifs de l'otan déployées dans ces
pays et concernant la france si on a
bien compris il va y avoir un
renforcement
de déploiement si vous voulez de soldats
et d'armes en roumanie clergé chez un de
nos alliés autant de l'otan bien sûr
c'est un peu le maximum que peut faire
le temps ciel renforcer le dispositif
militaire à ses frontières assez grande
frontière à l'otan qui vont sur 2700 km
le long le long de la russie même si à
la biélorussie entre la russie la
pologne quoique aujourd'hui avec ce qui
vient de se passer on ne sait plus si la
biélorussie est encore un pays
indépendant puisque des unités russes
sont intervenues pour marcher sur kiev
des chars visiblement depuis la
biélorussie